the story of little voices specs
and people around best finding their
voice i just don't have that thing
you're way too hard on yourself we knew
obviously this was going to be a story
of this young woman growing up in new
york and that meant it had to look like
it does which is to say a cast that
looks like the city every background
every color every religion every sexual
orientation
there is something so magical about
their chemistry you really felt like
there was a deep sense of trust between
them
it was just a really warm familial set
and that's the kind of set that i like
to create
we're in this together my character
pre-check is a musician struggling in
new york city
and she's also coming to terms with her
sexuality who you are is a choice it's
who you are
that's part of the reason why i wanted
to play ethan he experienced actually
quite horrible hardships and what's so
nice about him is how hopeful he is
that's what the show is isn't it it's
about finding the courage to do what you
believe in and to not
be led astray i'm just scared
everybody's scared
[Music]
you gotta do this we're just this young
diverse
group of people trying to find our
footing not just in new york but in life
we all have a lot of heart we all love
what we do and it shows
we've had such a wide range of
incredible actors which means their
characteristics and what they go through
how do we get to neverland
second star to the right and swayed
until morning
you just gain a new friendship along the
way with all these different
personalities coming together was one
it makes the show feel complete take it
away best
it's been really eye-opening for me and
being pushed in the deep end with this
show and it's the kind of magic you
don't find
all the time you find the people who
believe in you and it helps you believe
in yourself at times and i think that's
a really beautiful
way for us to engage with each other in
the world we're on our own now
this is our time
[Music]